frédéric la ville d'alep qui est l'enjeu
de cette bataille actuelle oui une ville
évidemment très importante en fait c'est
la deuxième ville la deuxième ville la
plus importante de la syrie c'est une
ville aussi qu' il y a trois ans à peu
près à une population d'un million et
demi de personnes
aujourd'hui après tous ces pilonnages
ces bombardements intempestif au
beaucoup de choses ont été détruites
en fait il y aurait juste quelques
centaines de milliers de personnes
mais c'est une ville évidemment qui est
très stratégique et c'est pour ça que ça
intéresse beaucoup de gens on est
proches quand même de la turquie on est
dans le nord de la syrie et regardez où
se situent les différentes forces en
présence si l état islamique
vous avez ici les forces kurdes près de
la turquie les rebelles qui eux sont
contre assad sont majoritairement masse
est ici à l'est pardon à l'ouest de
allaitent et regarder ce qui est en
train de faire en fait assad avec son
armée mais aussi avec les bombardements
russes
ils vont essayer en fait d'encercler de
couper les lignes de ravitaillement des
rebelles pour finalement gagner le
contrôle d'un épais beaucoup d'experts
pensent que celui qui va gagner à l'aip
bon en fait reprendre progressivement le
contrôle de la syrie et pour l'instant
c'est un avantage clair et net pour
vladimir poutine évidemment qui aide son
amie indéfectible
monsieur à sable plusieurs disent que ça
pourrait être un point tournant dans
cette guerre aux lions merci frédéric
arrou